I owe you an apology by the way oh why
is that an apology maybe you should say
this no no no no do it on there you know
you you used to tell me that you know
this whole Shadow Banning from Twitter
and stuff and I'm like oh dude please
come on like but it turns out it was you
were completely right like it was you
just you were telling me that all along
and I'm like you know I wasn't thinking
it was a conspiracy theory but now you
know Jack goes before calling you
basically lied he lied he lied I hope
they get him for perjury
someone like you who cares about truth
when you hear him say these things if
you're willing to grant me the the leash
that what I'm telling you right now is
true that gas prices for example he came
in we're about 2 30. they went up to
five now they're around 3 30. so they
are higher than when he took office and
then he says they're coming down it's a
complete it's just a verbal trick now I
have no doubt Trump did it I have no
doubt Obama did and everything else but
I think something's happening now where
the lies because of covid
are so everywhere in society and they
have been so uh debunked in real time
right that that people can't take it
anymore something feels different about
The Lies We can be lied to to a certain
degree and I think we're we're crossing
a threshold with the lies that is going
to do something very dangerous something
like that so so what are you asking then
so what I'm asking you is when you when
if you can grant me that what I just
told you it's true about gas prices and
inflation that it is true inflation was
here when he got into office then it
went here now it is down a little so his
argument eight percent right his
argument is that it's down but it's like
no it's not down from when you took over
it's down from the peak of it over the
side and the implication of that as its
causal the key caused it right there's
some some policy position or the fed or
something which is also dangerous that
they think as political beings and as
presidents that everything that happens
is because of them which is also
nonsensical right but what I'm asking
you specifically is in terms of the
manipulation of truth that they're all
constantly doing what do you think think
we do with that
boy that's a fantastic question you know
I think that's one way to bridge the
liberal Conservative Republican Democrat
divide is just stop denying reality I
mean one of the things that jumped out
at me in that talk and I don't know if I
think you've had Heather McDonald oh
many times yeah she's gonna come out in
a couple weeks yeah okay so she's great
at this Matt Thornton has a great book
The Gift of violence about this when he
was talking about the police and the
role of the police with young black men
yeah I mean that was just so contrary to
what the data is since George Floyd
homicide rates among among black men
have gone up 50 in my own city of
Portland Oregon they've gone up uh well
over 200 percent and that's another
story I'm happy to get into it but
that's another story together
um death from by young black men the
number one cause of death is other young
black men and that's the only true for
those quote unquote racial groups and so
I think denial of reality and not
stating think
we need to be blunt about facts and
evidence and not couch them in political
terms now when he talked about you know
whatever his value systems are and how
you can solve the problem that's another
thing but to blame the police for this
or to say that the police are causally
then you know I can't remember exactly
how we frame and that's just
not only is that it's false that's just
a complete denial of reality well not
only is it a denial of reality but I
think he does it as a bit of cover
because he can't lose his radical base
okay so that's that's a political okay
so that's the thing you need to signal
to your base and so I think that there
so I lost just just as a sign I lost a
thousand followers on my tweets last
night which I thought was kind of funny
I hope I got you I hope I got one or two
for you when I was kind of making money
yeah no I just kept laughing about it
because you know one it's good to not be
ideal captured by your own audience your
audience capture but the other thing is
I I think if you're not willing to cross
the line and say look if somebody does
something not everything Rhonda Sanders
if you're a lefty does is bad or not
everything but so many people they're
just not willing to cross the aisle and
say look this is true or this is false
um and you know Harris was up there you
know clapping you know robotically
clapping at these idiotic things that
are clearly divorced from reality I
don't know
in a two-party system
what the solution to that is given the
penalty for crossing the aisle Andrew
Yang and others have suggested well that
there is no solution you have a third
party
Etc I don't I don't know
I don't know what the solution is but I
do know that the environment is so toxic
right now for even saying you agree or
not only even that platforming going on
someone's show just talked to Brian
Keating this morning uh you know even
going on someone's Show when he did the
prayer review videos and the grief
people have gotten
from that that the left then won't have
you on because it's Constantine kissing
is another example I'm another example I
used to be able to go on all sorts of
things I owe you an apology by the way
maybe you should say this no no no no do
it on air you know you you used to tell
me that you know this whole Shadow
Banning from Twitter and stuff and I'm
like oh dude please come on like but it
turns out it was you were completely
right like it was you was you were
telling me that all along and I'm like
you know I wasn't thinking it was a
conspiracy theory but now you know Jack
goes before calling you basically lied
he lied he lied I hope they get him for
perjury he lied under Earth
as we're taping well the thing is and
what his lawyers will get him out of and
why no one ever goes okay
exactly they didn't it was a linguistic
trick they never called it Shadow
banding what did they call it they
called it uh what do they call it guys D
something it was de-escalation
yeah visual filter oh yeah or contextual
filtering something like that so they
were just playing with language
constantly well that's the other thing
everybody does is bamboozle everybody
through language the woke people are
particularly the wool crowd are
particularly good at that they just
Bamboozled people so okay so I have a
feeling we probably have less
disagreement on some of the policies
than than may we may even think but on
the race one yeah specifically and that
moment where he talked about how you
know when you get pulled over black and
brown people my children never had to be
told right that they had to keep their
hands on the wheel and blah blah it's
like I was actually told that yeah
that's what I said on my show this
morning my dad said the first time I
went out driving with my Dad we went to
uh HB Thompson Middle School parking lot
to go drive out there is because they're
you know it's big area I could drive and
before I even started doing anything he
said he said David if you ever get
pulled over you keep your hands on you
called you David yeah he called me David
he still calls me David you keep your
hands on the wheel and the fact that
Biden went out of his way to racialize
that totally so and also black and brown
the implication being that somehow this
is 100 million people and it's just so I
don't know if you have you had Wilfred
Riley on your show no I met him a few
times
and stuff I mean fantastic what a shame
that we have to live in a society where
I have to say to you well he's a black
academician like that shouldn't have
literally anything to do with it but he
has some some should I tell you about my
black friend Larry Elder right right see
right so we don't that's the other
that's the other kind of point of
commonality what should we do is we can
we should be able to agree that there's
a truth of the matter independent of
whatever immutable characteristic you
possess right so if we can't agree to
that then there's a just we're in I mean
it really isn't commensurable at that
point but
um the fact that we consistently
racialized this is a problem but here's
here's my pushback on that
because so many and I do that thing for
my YouTube channel where I go out and I
ask random people questions yeah and I
put them on a line from you know neutral
to strongly agree and strongly disagree
and they walk to the side what do you
call that by the way Spectrum Street
epistemology yeah so we're going to link
to the channel below yeah from my first
book I was in Eastern Europe is it
better to be rule it's better to be
ruled by the USA than Russia or the USA
than China all kinds of questions
homosexuality abortion trans everything
yeah but consistently one of the things
that I find in that is when I talk to
black people not African-Americans but
black people
they are they're pissed and they're
they're deeply they're not even deeply
concerned they're they're worried
they're fed up and I think we need to
have an honest conversation like is that
imaginary like is that are those
concerns they have how rooted in reality
are they if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about Academia check out our Academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell